- This is awkward.
(chuckles) I mean, we kinda
went on a date, didn't we?
And now you're angry with me,
but you're also fixing my sink. (chuckles)
- I'm fixing your mother's
sink as a favor for my father.
It's not about you.
- Good to go.
- And who are you?
- I'm Otis.
I guess we're partners for the project.
- Are you new?
- No, no, no, no.
I've been here since first year.
We had chemistry together last term.
You set my desk on fire.
Oh.
- Are you a complete moron?
- No, I'm not.
- That was a rhetorical question.
Don't touch my shit.
- Just trying to help.
- Don't.
- Why are your arms so freakishly long?
- They're not.
Just roll up your sleeves, you fool.
(upbeat music)
- Hello.
- Hi.
Okay.
You're on time.
- How long is this gonna take, new kid?
- Well.
- I'm already bored.
- I heard a thing.
- Okay.
- Go on, then, do your thing.
(upbeat music)
- This thing concerns
your virginal status.
- (chuckles) Excuse me?
I'm a virgin!
- What?
- I'm a virgin, and I thought
you should know that I am.
- Yeah, that's totally cool, no judgment.
- Cool, glad I shared.
- I heard on the grapevine
that your cherry remains unpopped.
- That's none of your business.
- Yeah, yeah, let's skip the faux modesty.
I'm down if you are.
- Down?
- Deflowering the maiden.
Breaking the lawn chair,
skinning the fish.
Your dick in my vagina, what do you say?
- Yeah. (clears throat)
- Have you got any Nesquik?
- Only Manna.
Cranberry juice is good for thrush!
You know, thrush is a vaginal discharge.
Wait, sorry, who are you?
- Whoever you want me to be.
Also, I'm Lily.
- I'm gonna head off now.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
You okay getting home?
- Yeah, I'll see you tomorrow.
- Did you know that whales
only have sex for 35 seconds?
Which is odd, actually,
because their penises
are seven feet long.
I reckon you could drown in their cum.
- Fascinating.
(woman moaning)
Mom!
You're not my mom. (chuckles)
And I've just, I'm not,
this is research. (chuckles)
(women moaning)
(upbeat music)
- You should probably
think about getting a lock
on this door.
Where's the bathroom?
(upbeat music)
- You're quite sexy.
- You're sexy too.
- I know.
(upbeat music)
- Jesus Christ!
- Oh! (chuckles)
- Can I touch your penis? (clears throat)
♪ Let me tell you one thing ♪
(both moaning)
- So, I'm giving out
free sex advice tonight.
If,
anyone got any STIs?
Okay.
Bye then.
- Hello.
Finished your research?
- My?
Yes, oh my god, yes, I did.
It was actual research, by the way.
It's hard to explain, but I
needed to know about scissoring.
- Okay.
- But can I just stay in here for a bit?
I want people to think I've had sex.
- Listen, I hear you.
Peer pressure's hard, but
living with regret is harder.
- No, sorry, I don't need therapy.
I just wanted Molly Bell
to see me coming in here,
so she thinks I've had sex.
You don't have to speak.
- Oh.
Right.
Okay.
- Was it your girlfriend?
- No. (chuckles)
Definitely not.
Just destined to be alone.
Your dad's inside, should I get him?
- No, don't bother.
(car honking)
- I'm gonna need
to take things slow.
(upbeat music)
- Do you have any music to set the mood?
- Hey, piss-flaps.
Something wrong with your phone?
- I don't have a phone!
What, I do, it's broken, right?
The reception, I need to get it fixed
at the Carphone Warehouse.
Thank goodness for insurance, phew.
- Stop speaking.
- (yelps) Sorry.
That was, I need a safe word.
Flamingo.
I'm not very experienced.
- You never called.
- I,
I composed a bunch of texts,
and after reading them, I
just felt immensely uncool,
so I decided to not text you anything.
I'm an idiot, sorry.
I've been thinking about your proposition.
Still interested?
- Yes.
- Great, fantastic.
- To be clear, I don't wanna
have sex with you specifically,
just a human man with a penis.
- That's great for my self-esteem.
I feel the same way. (chuckles)
Purely pragmatic.
School dance tonight.
- Right.
Are you going?
- It's an appropriated American tradition
that celebrates sexism
and peddles an unrealistic
portrayal of romantic love, so--
- I like dances.
- You do?
- Yeah, I think dancing is fun.
(Otis chuckles)
- [Girl] Would you like
to have sex with me?
- Do you?
Do you wanna go to the dance with me?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Okay, cool. (chuckles)
Well, it starts at eight, I think.
So, aim to get there for seven?
I'll pick you up at 6:30?
On time's late.
- I'll meet you at yours at seven.
- Okay.
(upbeat music)
- Do you wanna meet up this week?
- Tonight, your house.
I'll bring the condoms,
you bring the lube.
- No.
(birds chirping)
Do (clears throat), do you?